hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to a
second update of the LinkedIn $10,000
challenge the idea here is to generate
$10,000 a new business for my company
only using LinkedIn and I partnered up
with christina and Eric who are linked
in experts and having them help me
basically use their strategies to
generate new business for my company and
doing a video I guess case study of it
to show you how I'm going through the
process and the results that we're
getting so this is the second update
last week i posted about how i created
the group and put my first post and got
some first first comment on it this is
the this was the this is our post here i
created something to called what makes
it perfect tweet and got some comments
back on it I wrote to Eric and said Eric
you know you're going to love this
here's my group it's awesome where we
were to getting some comments on it
without me doing anything and he wrote
back to say delete your group that
you've created create a new group market
a small business with Evan Carmichael
and basically one who wanted me to do is
create a closed group not an open one
indeed the idea here is that so he wrote
it here I don't want people to be able
to view your content and leave I want
them to actually join your community I
also want them to go to the group
profile page where I show them the value
of joining so I now have to delete my
group and set a new group and keep it
closed i'm going to walk through that
process right now so i'll go create a
group and you wanted to call it
marketing to small businesses with Evan
Carmichael it's great group type will
pick professional group summary I might
changes later but right now let's just
go with helping brands connect with and
market to to the small business
community I'm sure Eric will have some
thoughts for me after seeing this put
that in the description website but
still they're perfect access request to
join and where is it going to be here
this is going to be here create a
members-only group so that was the key
thing and once you create a group you
can't change you could change the name
you
change more information about it but you
can't change if it's open or closed so
that's why I have to delete the first
group and create the members only group
so we're going to do that right now and
we'll skip the invitation step have that
happen later okay well I guess you do
have the option to switch to an open
group but you can't switch back if you
want to so i'll have that there and i
wanted to start off with having just a
quick discussion so that i could get
some promotion going on there so the
first first one i had i already wrote up
a document here i can just pull it into
the screen it's a word document and
talking about brian's having a value
proposition and the big challenge here
is a lot of these brands who have
websites for small businesses they don't
have any value proposition so it doesn't
it doesn't explain clearly on the web
page what it's all about why i should be
here why should you take that next step
and so i'm basically explaining how
that's a problem is showing some
examples so I'll pop that in here sort
of discussion and as I scroll to get the
content pop that in here and it'll click
share so we'll put that up now so this
is my new linkedin group parking the
small business with Evan Carmichael and
as we get more updates i'll keep you
guys posted i'm going to run this by
eric and his team and see what he thinks
what else we should be doing here and as
i get some updates and progress i will
let you guys know the other thing that
i'm actively doing is I'm participating
in another group thats related to for me
it's b2b social media and being an
active member there but it's it's
something that hopefully will generate
some business but the main strategy here
is to create our own groups and try to
generate some business through it so
I'll keep you guys posted in the coming
weeks if you like this video please give
it a thumbs up below if you have a
question about what you're going to do
on linkedin or about this process please
let me know in the comments below and I
and Eric will probably check it out and
give some feedback as soon as we can so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode